let's talk about the new york city
mayoral primary
yesterday we had the democratic mayoral
primary in new york city
and the republican mayoral primary in
new york city
uh there were high hopes among some that
former democratic presidential candidate
andrew yang
would do well in the democratic primary
canned
uh new york city mayoral race he came
out to a fast start polling really
really well in early polls
although that started to fade part of
the belief
that the fade of andre yang was because
of early name recognition he jumped
ahead because of early name recognition
from the democratic primary
um also questions about uh i guess we
would call it the authenticity of andrew
yang as a new yorker and and
i there were all sorts of kind of
xenophobic overtones to that there is no
question
that there was an aspect of the
opposition to accepting andrew yang as a
real new yorker
came from some anti-asian xenophobia
and also there was the sense that andrew
yang
having lived out of the city for a long
time
was not a real new yorker in that sense
as well
disaggregating some xenophobia from the
accurate understanding of andrew yang's
residence a complicated and difficult
thing and important not to
invalidate any aspect of that because
all of it were important asp
all of those aspects were relevant but
ultimately it did not go well
for andrew yang the results as we have
them right now
have eric adams uh leading it is a
ranked choice um election and right now
you have eric adams leading
at just shy of 32 percent on the
democratic side
with maya wiley up close to 10 points
behind
at 22 katherine garcia
closely behind maya wiley in third place
at 19 and a half percent and then
pretty significantly further down with
only uh about a third of the support of
the leading candidate eric adams
andrew yang at 11.7
scott stringer and diane morales
combining for just shy of eight percent
over on the republican side
um curtis sliwa quite a well-known
face and uh figure in new york city now
for decades of course of guardian angels
fame curtis lee what easily winning the
republican primary
with about 72 percent of the vote over
fernando mateo
here is a video of andrew yang who is
all about
math and the numbers rightly coming out
last night and saying
i don't have the numbers i simply don't
have the numbers take a listen to this
campaign but you all know i am
a numbers guy right i'm someone who
trafficks
in what's happening
uh by the numbers and i am not going to
be
the next mayor of new york city based
upon the numbers that have come in
tonight
i am conceding this race
though we're not sure ultimately who the
next mayor is going to be
but whoever that person is i will be
very happy to work with them campaign
now a bunch of people coming out and
saying
you know what what what pomposity from
andrew yang
why would the eventual mayor work on
anything
with the fourth place finisher in the
democratic primary i didn't see it that
way i saw it simply as an act of good
faith i don't think that is a big deal i
think the more interesting story however
is
how uh new york city is an interesting
place
in that the voters really did not seem
to care
about the name recognition of andrew
yang it helped him
early but it did not carry him to the
finish line and now we are going to see
um the general election get going new
york city
interesting as a it's not necessarily a
barometer nationally but there are a lot
of things in new york city
that relate to issues that many cities
across the country
are dealing with there are questions now
about how to deal with
what are widely perceived to be
short-term but certainly upticks in
certain types of crime and later today
joe biden is going to have a big event
related to gun violence
um there are also uh questions about
you know there there's been a um
a sort of bifurcation at the local and
semi-local level about how politics
should be focused in the united states
there are all these
national issues and cultural issues that
are getting a lot of attention when you
watch fox news and cnn and msnbc
um and there have been attempts to
insert
those as the important issues into local
races
in some places to a degree it's worked
where local races become about
will the city council boycott israel
or will we make a statement
about critical race theory as examples
but what i am seeing in new york city
is that voters really seem to care much
more about
local economic issues local issues of
public transit and rent prices
and really that nitty gritty which takes
me back to the james carville 1990s
perspective of it's the economy stupid
it's not seeming to me like making local
races
about national cultural or even
irrelevant to the local race foreign
policy issues
that seems to be uh coming through in
the results that we're seeing
in new york city so we're going to
follow the race even though it's a local
race because it has a lot of
national implications let me know your
thoughts about what happened to andrew
yang in new york city
um i laid out what i think held him back
let me know what you think you can find
me on twitter at deepakman we're going
to take a quick break and we've got
really just a packed program for you
today
during the pandemic and even at this
point i try to avoid
physically visiting a doctor's office
unless i really have to and that's why i
love our sponsor
steadymd primary care you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician who's a good fit for you
you have a one-hour virtual appointment
and you start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone and video chat and unlike
other services
this isn't some random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md
has a limited number of patients so they
can give you the personal attention you
deserve
they can help you with anything your
primary care doctor
normally would healthy diet managing
conditions weight loss sleep
depression anxiety you don't need
insurance it's just 99
a month with absolutely no other fees or
co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you
go to steadymd.com pacman there's no
risk
no long-term commitment the link is
right underneath this video